what are some common mistakes that you
see web series creators make over and
over again oh gosh I think one of one of
the things is that a lot of people don't
understand exactly what a web series is
and sometimes that what they're trying
to do is they're trying to take maybe a
script that they a film script that's
like a hundred but like 100 minutes or
90 minutes and what they're trying to do
is they're trying to cut it up into
episodes so that it would be like this
is my movie and I'm cutting it up so the
problem is that when when it's shown web
series audiences are very fickle people
and the main thing is because you know
we got that little mouse and we can
click on that thing and tell you if you
want to or television set you just click
the remote and if you change channels
and you can click and go up go to
another web series very very easily if
you don't catch someone's attention
right away and people don't understand
that you can't just take a film script
and chop it up and that's it
you have 90 minutes or a hundred minutes
to tell a whole story you need to
capture somebody's attention right away
within the first two or three minutes so
a lot of people especially because I'm
with a little LA web fest I'm on there
they're bored and one of our common
complaints when we get people sending in
things in is they will have web series
that are sometimes 15 20 25 minutes long
that's not a web series that's a short
film and so we in fact a lot of the web
web fests people now we're trying to
limit it to keep it because a web series
is this it we like to show them and we
like to show as many episodes as we can
but we can't if somebody's got 25 minute
episodes then it's taking up too much
time so we tell people a web series you
know if it's comedy it shouldn't be
longer than about 6 minutes if it's a
drama no more than 8 to 10 minutes at
the most per episode so I think it's
understanding that web series should be
looked at as
some its own medium and not that oh this
is a movie and just cut up into little
pieces interesting and how many episodes
would you recommend most web series have
you know the average web series I've
seen some that were as little as maybe
four or five episodes for one season I
would say the average is eight to ten a
season you know and dramas tend to be
slightly longer as I mentioned that most
of them I would say are between eight to
ten minutes and the comedies are usually
more like four to six minutes some of
them are are as short as a minute and a
half two minutes what are your thoughts
of a web series creator making a web
series and aiming for sponsorship right
away I'm hearing that from a lot of
Webster's we all we're looking for spot
and that's like the only goal behind it
well if you don't have a if you don't
have a product you're not going to get a
sponsor I mean it's like it's the same
thing as saying okay I got to find a
studio to distribute my movie well you
haven't written the movie yet so I think
a lot of people get misled into thinking
well as long as I have this crowdfunding
campaign going and I can get money
raised then you know I can I can do all
of this
most of the webseries people that I've
talked to a lot of them they just
started off just because they felt they
needed to do it and they wanted to do it
now they gende they had so much fun it
was just a bunch of people a lot of
times they were cousins or brothers and
sisters siblings or some a lot of times
it was just kids in a dorm that just
decided let's let's do one you know and
they just did it and they would we've
had some that have been as primitive as
just using your iPhone and we had some
that have been very sophisticated where
you know they actually he's wonderful
you know technical things with camera
and stuff like that and some have one
you know brilliant you know special
effects and all that it just depends on
where you're at and what your story is
some of the more successful stories
though I think
are the ones that are done just because
these people felt they needed to be done
and they just they and they had an
interesting set of characters in an
unusual circumstance as an example you
know some of this I love the stories
that come behind the webseries and and
one of the things that that I've that
I've been doing is I've been asked to go
to the different web fests around the
world talking about web series that
concern social issues and it was very
interesting is that one of them is
called fafsa teen and it was about a
there basically it was called faceting
because it was about a situation in
Lebanon in Beirut Lebanon the creator of
it her name is Katya and she she lived
in and you know grew up in in Lebanon
middle-class family or upper-middle
class I don't know it but they they
owned some apartments and she did her
college work in London because there
weren't any universities that she felt
that she could go to in in Lebanon that
would support the fact that she wanted
you do communication and television and
stuff like that so it was she her family
sent her up there she actually did quite
well she started working for the BBC and
she was there al Jazeera contact because
she could just be you know several
different languages and she even got
some awards for her work but her parents
were getting older and so she made the
decision to move back to Beirut and you
know stay with her her family for a
while and maybe see if maybe things how
things were there and she realized when
she met with some of her friends that
she had grown up with that a lot of
things had gotten worse in in Lebanon
they you know of course had had you know
there were some bombings and and there
were areas where where neighborhoods
where it used to be safe and they're no
longer safe and she
realized there was something that she
wanted to say and she felt that women
especially were the ones who who are not
progressing in Lebanon her faceting is
about three women who eventually become
best friends and one is her husband has
left her with their kid at his parents
place he's through with marriage he
doesn't want that he doesn't want to be
married he doesn't want to be a father
and she is left by herself with her with
their young child and with the in-laws
and she doesn't know what she should do
she just if she does not get along with
the in-laws they blame her for
everything wah yet my our has our son
wouldn't have left if you were a good
wife or you were a good mother and
constantly blaming her so she needs to
find a place to stay she ends up staying
finding a place to stay in an apartment
building and the gal who this the
daughter of the apartment owner is very
creative and and she likes to make
movies and she likes to you know she's
just curious about things and she writes
and she does poetry and she's just very
creative and her father keeps saying
when are you just gonna settle down and
get married I should just marry you off
and of course she doesn't want that and
so the father those I mean they're the
parents are well-meaning but they're
very old-fashioned about it but she she
talks sweet talks her father and
accepting this woman to be in one of
their apartments the woman has to work
and so she takes the the son she needs a
tutor for Oh she'd know what is know she
she's a tutor and so she tutors for this
woman who is very wealthy and seek but
she has a couple of kids but her husband
works in Dubai and so she's by herself
but she's got a nanny she's got all this
but she needs a tutor so the woman who's
whose divorce is the tutor but it's
these three women who actually become
very good friends and what she did at
the end of
each web series was they got to vote on
the ending the audience the audience's
got to vote for the ending and then they
would show the ending at the beginning
of the next episode
on them which everyone got the vote and
I asked her well why did you do that and
she said I wanted to give women the
opportunity to vote to have an option
because they have so few options in my
country oh and FAFSA teen won the grand
prize at the Marseilles web fest Wow and
I'm sorry what was the name of her a
teen Fawcett a yes okee en great yeah
and it's a it's an amazing one
you